welcome to this video playing long
sagene my Revis something from Mexico
and vanilla with 93 okay is capture yeah
I don't want to recapture immediately
that's not really a threat interesting
very interesting move water never see
that okay let's just recap Champlain
normal moves it shouldn't be too bad i
can't play before here I didn't but what
I wanted to say is this some looks
active but might be questionable I said
yeah and I've gotta I gotta quickly for
coming I mean it's not terrible for
white but must be cautious with those
early openings offer of the queenside
yeah is quick on d1 air on d5
yeah again every move instantly like
it's so easy yelda for him kill him I've
got everything lined up to play this and
he can he's playing instantly I don't I
don't understand what what people are
doing ready and he too is just a piece
or not and what they play like that all
the time against me in recent games and
I stood on wind yeah but this is just a
PCM takes Bishop takes this easy rook
takes Bishop takes d4 yeah yeah rd5 this
even have to hanging so on white resides
yeah well at least a win for it not like
it is a piece of art but I won a game
hooray um yeah what I was trying to say
with before that this is yeah it looks
normal but you must be must be a bit bit
cautious with your development it can be
it can easily backfire let's look here
yeah here he must be a he must define as
a threat he must do something against it
not not entirely sure what it is the
queen is on this on this rook file maybe
h3 or something yeah this this already
gets gets very very tricky and the
compass on minus 1.5 already yeah it's
very difficult to to to to move even
if you just move the night somewhere
let's say let's say here I just go out
of this and he's in a really bad pin the
queen is very unlucky only three years
it always is a temple we are like that
it's always a temple and therefore we
strayed away losing the relatively best
seems to be b5 and this is not exactly
an obvious smooth my day five Queen
somewhere yeah that's also looks very
fishy no nights you for being the best
yeah well why does in bad shape he just
played it far too quickly i mean i'm
really a lame duck but dashing all moves
instantly a sister's can can backfire
alright thanks for watching